and the Senate decided to delay Brett
Cavanaugh's confirmation vote for a week
in order to enable an FBI investigation
everyone who is not Jeff Flake
understood the point of it the
investigation itself was irrelevant for
Democrats the only purpose was to buy
time so that new people some of them
anonymous Lee could make allegations
against Cavanaugh that's exactly what
happened of course and we've been the
first to scoff at some of these claims
because some have been frivolous
unfounded some have been absurd but
tonight we must tell you a new and
troubling story has emerged they could
alter the trajectory not simply the
Cavanaugh nomination but of the history
of this country it is a story of a young
man outwardly respectable but so morally
distorted within so addled by chronic
dependency on draft beer the witnesses
say he committed a particularly heinous
form of assault in a public place this
man this monster in human form once
tossed an ice cube at someone in a bar
yes an ice cube the perfect weapon in
solid form deadly and then within hours
it melts and evaporates into the air all
physical evidence turns to vapor there
are no fingerprints it's diabolical the
perfect crime and frankly from a
constitutional standpoint it is
disqualifying now we'll concede that we
miss the significance of this story at
first but the other networks were on it
long before we were watch their coverage
police documents that show that Brett
Kavanaugh threw ice in someone's face
threw ice in someone's face accused him
of throwing ice used Cavanaugh of
throwing ice on him the nominee threw
ice on him accused him of throwing ice
on him for quote some unknown reason ice
skate well the founders the framers of
our Constitution anticipated this very
moment article 3 of the Constitution in
words well-known to every first-year law
student our unequivocal on the subject
quote whoever shall throw ice in a
tavern is disqualified from service in
the federal judiciary end quote game
over
and yet ladies and gentlemen there is
more tonight a former Yale student
called tadlo who apparently over
with Brett Kavanaugh in school has
contacted the FBI with a brand new
outrage Lowe says that at one time at a
frat party some fraternity brothers
hired a prostitute to put on some kind
of show that Lowe found offensive now
what does this have to do with the Brett
Kavanaugh you might wonder well as Lowe
concedes nothing directly quote I can't
say for certain that Judge Cavanaugh was
present in the frat house and yet and
this is the critical part of this story
Brett Kavanaugh may have been in the
state of Connecticut when this happened
the very same state at the very same
time that people in a fraternity house
were doing things that Ted Lowe didn't
like need we say more
totally and utterly disqualifying still
confused watch CNN they'll explain there
been a lot of stories like this lately
you may have noticed Julie sweat Nick
for example claims that 37 years ago for
some reason she went to ten gang rape
parties in a row in suburban Maryland
and that Brett Kavanaugh may have been
at some of them what did Brett Kavanaugh
do at these parties
well sweatin excite a sworn statement
suggesting that Kavanaugh and friends
added drugs and alcohol to the punch
that facilitated the rapes that took
place at these parties now that's a very
serious charge except as sweatiness
sweating just explained in a televised
interview she didn't really mean it I
saw him around the punch I won't say
bowls or the punch containers I don't
know what he did but I saw him buy them
yes well you've heard Democrats talk a
lot recently about how Brett Kavanaugh
may have lied under oath there's no
evidence for that there is now though
quite a bit of evidence that Julie sweat
Nick just did Democrats don't care
they're not interested in finding out
because hey whatever works power is the
point and yet they should care sexual
assault is a horrifying crime no matter
who commits it all decent people
understand that false claims
trivialize the offense and there have
been a number of widely publicized false
claims over the past 15 years and the
undermine the many assault victims who
are telling the truth they make the
search for justice seem political which
it never should be and worst of all
they are making the rest of us nearly as
cynical as professional Democrats
already are that's a high cost